こんにちは(重い空気からのスタート)
(パパパパ)
はじめしゃちょーです
んー
いつからでしたかねー
私
中古ショップで
とある　和人形を
購入したんですよねぇー.....。
ぱっと見↑ぃ↓ー…
凄ぉく 不気味な人形でしたが(発表風)【￥300円(税抜き)】
何故か私は
その人形に魅力を感じまして
ついつい(テヘ)
買ってしまったわけですよぉ…。((罪な男だぜ…))
(横向きながら)わぁ！！！！！！【突然の脅かし】
(バンダガラガラダダダン)
ッハッハッハッハ
(タッ！)
こちらの人形です
この人形を買ってからぁー
約二カ月がたちました。
ある部屋にずっと置かれていたんですがぁ
その部屋の周りで
変なことが起きているんですよ
わぁ！　怖い。いや、あの、本当の話です。
それも僕だけじゃなくてなんか僕だけだったらなんか　うわ
うわぁ うわぁ やらせっぽいになると思うんですけども僕以外の方もねちょっと変な
現象にあったりしております
後輩君も、すごい色んな現象にあっているみたいです。会いました？
後輩A))えっと…。　ほんと怖い現象に会いました。　　簡単に説明するとぉ、金縛りにあった…
後輩A))ていうことなんですけどぉ…。
はじめ))(横向きながら)わぁ！！！！！！【突然の脅かし】(２回目)
はじめ))ッハ↑ッハ↑ッハ↑
はじめ))ねー。すぐ来たもんねー。
はじめ))そのあとは大丈夫だったの？
後輩A))そのあとで、まぁ、まだその時にはみんなに伝えてなかったんですけど。
後輩A))ほかの友達…は、その時ちょっと起きてたんですけど
はじめ))あ、言ってたねぇ。でもぉ。
後輩A))その友達に今なんか向こうの部屋から〈ドン〉っていう音聞こえたぁ？って言ったら
後輩A))さっきも(？)聞こえた聞こえたぁーって言って(ここまでです。すみません。)
を 待っ て まず で 強い 助け て から つい て 強い ため に この 話 の 続き な ん です けど そう
後 音 から しまっ て セグ子 常 に き て また 寝 た ん です けど ちょっと 信じ て なく て 若干 は ふざけ ん
じゃ ねー ぞ と 思っ て 僕 が 次 その 話し ぶり に 会っ た 部屋 の 近く に 寝 た ん です よ
そ し たら 今度 僕 が 金縛り に あっ て しまい まし た
それぞれ 月 です なん か ね オイラー の 時 は な 人形 から の 金縛り と いう か
純正 に 金縛り に あっ てる か ね 普通 に 動け ねぇ みたい な 感じ だっ た ん で あんまり なんか 人形 から 来 卓球
感じ 品 か わかん ない ちょっと 分 深く 考え すぎ て なかっ た の か も 知れ ん ね 分かん ない けど とりあえず
カレー が 始まり あっ て お 金 も 人 が い た ん です けど その 人 が
は この ビデオ が タイヤ から 音 を 聞い た と 通っ て と いう わけ で です ね ちょっと あの 子 の
尿 が 原因 か は わから ない ん です けど も この 人形 が あっ た 部屋 で 明らか に ちょっと 素敵 な 現象 が
僕 だけ じゃ なく て いろんな 人 たち が あっ て おり ます
動画 に とり 亭 な こん だけ いろんな こと は カルビ 伸び て なん か わかん ない です この 人形 で ん か どう か
も わかん ない し た 僕 ら の
思い込み か も しれ ない し それ が ちょっと わから ない の で 今回 の 動画 で は もう 一度 その
いろいろ 芸者 方 変 に こと に 気 を 戻し て
奴 は 来 た と 言っ た だけ
バッハ もう 一度 この 人形 を その 辺 に 戻し て 今 から 彼 と 僕 で ちょっと でる ん で 寝 てる ところ ちょっと
動画 に 撮っ て み て ね が 起き ない か
確かめ て みよう と 思い ます 本当 に 何 か あっ たら ちゃんと 動画 で 何か ある と 思う の で 確かめ て いる と
思い ます で 俺 の かあ さん 曰く 悪い 奴 じゃ ない ん です よ この 子 で この 子 学
来る 前 から あの 家 で また 怪しい 冷気 が ある みたい な から ちょい 将生 と か も 出 て た ん で ひょっと
し たら 守っ て くれ て たら か も しれ ない です
わかん ない です
結構 最中 の 話 な だけ 中 に 何か が 起き て いる よう な 気 が する の で 押し込み て みよう と 思い
ます レッツ ズルい
一 杯 と いう わけ で この 部屋 が 倍 の 部屋 に なっ て おり ます
以上 です ね 人形 あっ た 場所 か この 辺 か な ここ ら へん is 遠い だっ た ん です よ
売っ ちゃっ 書い てる ねー もう 既に 始まっ て ます ね
いや もう ほんと この 人形 の せい じゃ ない と 思う よ ね な 母ちゃん よく 当たる か な
むしろ こいつ 良い 奴 説 が ある ん です けど も もう コネ 湯 だけ で 鳥肌 本土 と 同じ ぐらい ちょっと 怖い です ね
前 は ね ここ で 動画 とっ て た ん です けど 最近 ここ も 編集 ベア と し て 選ん だ 空気 を 利用
し て 集中 し て 編集 する 今 編集 版 に し て おり ます さて これ から 後輩 の 二人 で 寝る 付 の
この 謎 の 編 何 が 起きる の でしょう か
ここ は やばい 地 と 本当 に 緊張 し て き た それ で は ね ます
As み なさい 覚え ござい お やすみ
あー 怖い 怖い 言っ こう やっ ふうう ううう さあ 危険 だ
ん
お わかり いただけ た だろう か
と いう 小さな 音 の 後 に
カ ヅ カっ
女性 の ぐっ
近 さ を 感じ た 女性 の 植木 声 の よう な 声 が 聞こえ て いる ん
ふーん ん うん
人形 ず たい 特に 何か 起き た わけ で も なく
我々 2人 が
金縛り に あう こと も なかっ た か な トーン 8 月 度 も 道 と は 夜中 じゅう なり 続け て い た ん
そして 夜中 に 謎 の インター
いい と 思っ
誰 が 来 た の だろう か
そして
ん おっ
ぷうぷう
うーん で さ
て ます よ
いっ 4 日